I kind of like I'm feeling the uh
drawbacks of living on the ground floor
in a house now
holy [__] [__] uh I've just been
having to deal with like cockroaches
recently you know do you know what I'm
like starting to think um
I have to clean your house no no my
house is actually like genuinely pretty
clean because uh they we found out where
they're coming from and that's just like
the drains because it's summer right now
and every time we see a cockroach it's
basically like they're like tiny tiny
cockroaches they're not like the Giga
Chad cockroach you're getting like uh
Australia or in Thailand so I'm like
before if I heard cockroach I'd be like
[__] terrified but now I see the one
the tiny ones in Japan I'm like you're a
little baby before it was a Dark Souls
boss yeah and now it's like a tutorial
now it's just like a slight annoyance
because I see I see them like sometimes
uh in the bathroom when I'm just going
and I'm like for [__] like stop
crawling out of the drains police is it
just me or do I feel like do you feel
more I guess scared or in danger when a
cockroach appears in like somewhere like
a bathroom drain or like say when you're
showering for example and it appears in
the bathroom as opposed to anywhere else
I don't know why I feel more vulnerable
because I'm naked no I like it more I I
like it more I can send them back to
where the [__] they came I like it more
because one I don't have to worry about
making a mess because I can just clean
that [__] up right away yeah so if
you're gonna murder someone yeah you do
in the bathroom yeah the tiles yeah yeah
sure number two yeah well I mean you
know it's from experience no I'm just I
I imagine that killing someone then if
you killed them and then there was
carpet everywhere you'd be like oh for
[__] say yeah my house doesn't have
carpets yeah yeah but like I most most
new house clean yeah and uh yeah number
two I like the fact that it's like in
the bathroom because I know where I came
from if it was in the kitchen or the
living room I'm like how the [__] did
you get in where the f are you do you
have friends do you have friends do you
have friends the children The Wine
Cellar gone yeah sure as this marvelous
God I'm glad I stumbled in here
what I've realized every time I see you
like it's only happened twice by the way
this year
um
what like what I've realized is that if
I see one I cannot let that [__] out
of my sight I don't know why but this
one can't [__] like run off yeah okay
so like you need something together with
I'm not metal enough to like [__] use
my hand or whatever just yet I'm not
that Australian right right you're not
my time now right I try and get a ticket
I'll go for the foot though yeah but the
first like the first time this happens I
don't want to touch with my hands but
I'll crush with my feet but then it'll
be on your socks yeah it'll be on your
socks yeah but I don't want one I'm
watching them anyway
same thing with your hand I'll wash it
anyway
yeah I guess so I mean I wouldn't be
against crushing with my hands right
yeah it depends well because I already
annoyed one time I bought that cockroach
killer that's everywhere in Japan and in
that fridge yeah this [__] just tanked
it yeah I felt like he was like Kirito
in that one scene where he's getting
slashed I just felt like he was regening
quicker than I was
concrete I was doing damage over time
attacks and he was just like my regen is
greater you are nothing to me but then
if I went like he'd be dead yeah yeah uh
and so I was you know I think seeing
that site where he just tanked he didn't
even move that's what pissed me off yeah
he didn't even like care to try and
Dodge it like he was so impervious to it
that he was like and what what are you
going to do okay
yeah so I was like well [__] it I'll
slap him so I did I tried to stomp on
him uh but I missed they're [__] fast
[__] yeah they are false little
antennas tell them when the foot's
coming yeah I always wondered did they
see life in slow-mo they must do they
must right yeah
like instincts like anime characters
whether you're like teleport behind like
I could send your presence teleports
behind you nothing personal I feel like
they know when you're looking at them as
well because this has happened like
every time I've seen one I have looked
at it I'm like oh there's a cockroach
that has approached my field of view and
I stare at it I'm like you're not going
anywhere you're not going anywhere and
it's like totally still okay I'm like it
turns into a DBZ fight yeah yeah and I'm
like okay I know the tissue's there I'm
gonna look away for a second and you're
still gonna be there
it's gone like it just like they're like
yeah
because then flies right I don't know
how flies can do it I forgot how they
can do it but they can sense the
difference in air pressure yeah so when
something's approaching the air pressure
they I obviously is so small that you
can feel the air pressure yeah
um so I imagine maybe it's something
like that I don't know it must be what's
up okay question
would you
would you would you get all of the
benefits of antennas uh but you had to
be a normal person with antennas
you could you could literally get all
the benefits of having contenders but
you just have antennas what's the
benefit yeah what are the benefits
sensing the presence of someone coming
insane yeah air pressure differentials I
think that would just [__] me up because
I wouldn't really know you'd adjust
because you'd be born with it you
wouldn't just have it but I'd also just
be like [__] when I want a plane uh
yeah like I'd get on just be like oh
like I already suffer with the ear
popping and then I have to deal with the
antenna just be like I'm not sure I'm
sure if a cockroach got on the plane
it'd survive it'd be all right well yeah
those things will survive anything so
the point is would you okay what would
you be willing what deformity would you
be willing to accept
of like a of would you take wings and
hoppy uh no no because because if you
think about it Wings in human society
would suck to have ever yeah it would
also like how it's gonna fit in I'm sure
you can fly but yeah you've got to fit
in but it's not worth flying you know
like you know you could just [__]
build a device to fly better than you
know you still wouldn't I when I when I
say fly you're not suddenly impervious
to like pressure differentials of yeah
it'd be like a few hundred meters in the
sky yeah exactly I feel like flying such
a [__] overpowered no no over like uh
overvalued overvalued over I've become
obsessed with the idea of having
superpowers with severe drawbacks
so you can have something but you get
[__] why I think it's fun it's fun
hypothetical like you get wings but you
also have gonorrhea like will you take
it
like you're at the massive you're the
the biggest dick ever but you can't have
sex
yeah you just can't get all right just
having the biggest dick ever would be
its own Nerf because no girl wouldn't
want to have sex yeah that's true that's
a good point okay what about
um this is just like uh you were able to
yeah you were able to photosynthesize
but you would you would have a lingering
sense of hunger but you weren't allowed
to eat
why would I want to be able to
photosynthesize [__] love food why
would you pay for it huh yeah but it's
worth it yeah but that's that's worth it
like if I could you like the burden of
paying if I would put photosynthesized
then I would get fat on sunlight and I
don't want to do that I guess I can't
get that you can't get fat obviously you
know what I mean it's hugely obese dude
he's just like God I'm so hungry I'm so
hungry dude yeah just like you go you go
on like a beach holiday for one okay
like one week and you're like [__] oh
I didn't even [__] eat any drink any
cocktails you can get invisible but you
have to get blackout drunk this is
make sure to spin off to Darker Than
Black I've ever seen did you ever watch
darker than last yeah yeah yeah a number
of cigarettes containing nitroglycerine
[__] me already I mean none of these
Powers I actually want I don't want to
be invisible all right tell me a power
you want I'll tile drawback okay
um I mean we've talked we've talked
about teleportation before you could
teleport so you can tell them all but
you have no way but you [__] yourself
every time I actually was gonna do
something like that but honestly I think
you could you could easily plan around
that that's not that's not enough for
drawback you can teleport but every time
you teleport
someone
someone you've met in your life dies
oh so you could be you're risking like
how many people you met in your life
like well we kind of [__] Facebook
friends yeah literally like if you have
if you have met would be like you've
exchanged words with someone could be
someone you bumped into sorry on the
subway you've anyone you've encountered
um if if that is the drawback then once
I am aware of that like drawback I would
just go out into public and start
talking to everyone yeah you would yeah
yeah but it would be like you'd still
have that lingering chance that could be
a close friend and if you teleported
would you do it would you take it no no
yeah you would no I mean despite the
ethical
um choice of killing a human life every
time you wouldn't know they wouldn't
know you'd never be found guilty
obviously that doesn't help yet but
there's nobody would never you would
never be held you would never be held
console like held accountable for this I
mean are we ignoring the fact that you
would be killing someone every time you
could also die too yeah why can you meet
yourself yeah
I would use it for emergencies like
let's say oh yeah no of course it's like
crazy happened you're like no you say
that but you're probably gonna get to
the point where you're like [__] I need
to go to the company
as like a pure like life or death
situation and then in about like I was
gonna say five years but I've just I
think more accurately like five months
for you okay it will get to the point
where you're going to the toilet using
teleportation
Joe give me a power I'll give you a
drawback well what power do you want uh
oh I like teleportation but I want to
hear your power I'll make a drawback my
power
reading Minds maybe reading Minds I
wouldn't want that power reading minds
but every time you read a mind uh
you oh okay I sing in like some way of
having a drawback where you get [__]
up by keep reading Minds yeah just
[__] with your head what about what
about the drawback of you can delete
mine okay you can read minds but you it
is hard for you sometimes to distinguish
which memories are yours and which are
theirs
I think that's what just happened it
just sounds like schizophrenia you know
you develop every time you read a mind
you'd get you'd partially be assisting
your own schizophrenia yeah yeah maybe
not okay
how about my favorite type now useless
Powers with useless drawbacks okay okay
uh what if you will never ever spill a
drink ever again in your life
but you can never drink again but
you have to eat at least one Olive every
single day otherwise you lose the power
and someone dies
and you have no legs
[Music]
olives from a specific Olive maker in
Italy yeah
do you have any olives from John perion
what if they just run what if like the
chain supply chain just runs out why is
there a strong zero who got the strong
zero why did we bring you on the ball
you want to join in can I yeah come on
drink on the job why not
allow it black pepper
this is this is the gun this is the
golden chips
black pepper oh I do love black pepper
you want to level one okay okay I should
have had more than just a [__] salad
before drinking this wine man this is my
problem every time every time and after
every time I'm after dark you guys are
like oh we got a fat Curry and I'm like
I had a I had a salad today double wine
please
I don't need plates what are we in the
21st century give me another one what's
another power up you will be able to you
will enjoy all media
200 more than you currently do you'll
get that much like drawback and and
serotonin from it however
the one in five chance of constantly
spoiling it for your friends and you
can't help it I take that yeah
that's easy yeah [__] I think people
will have that superpower right now
that's actually exists that's just uh
your average [__] fan account that's
your average one piece yeah
holy [__] I used I forgot how much I did
not miss Stan accounts on Twitter until
like and like when a hot new Shonen is
yeah log on to Twitter and I see this
[__] Jujutsu guys and fan account and
there's like Gojo and the new guy in
like the like his friends yeah and then
the manga panel they're like really
close and in the anime they're like
two inches more further apart okay and
they're like I can't believe they've
done this they've ruined the show
they've ruined it and I'm like oh my God
I do not miss Stan accounts oh thank you
so okay here's one for you you can run
at the speed of sound
Sonic is like Sonic you can run at Sonic
Speed but you're a Sonic fan
but in order for you to run at Max Speed
you need to be constantly shooting
yourself
literally die from uh just nutrition
loss because you'd literally run out of
poop and then your body would not have
any poop left so it just like sucks yeah
so you have to like eat as you run to
maintain it
how would that work this is a superpower
that's very similar to real life okay
you will have unlimited money for you
your friends and your family and
everything but at least once a day you
have to complete a full report
Commission
um how detailed are we talking I think
very hard I need to find the clients I
think I don't just come to you I think
you just described everything yeah
that's just that's just a very porn
artist because yeah what knows how much
[__] money they make yeah exactly